make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are picking back up again
with dark side war this time we're
covering the flash one shot the flash
tie into everything that's going on now
keep in mind these tie-ins take place
between the ending of act two
and the beginning of act three but one
thing that i want to draw your attention
to is a question that i got from a lot
of you guys in the comments section
who were asking how it is that like the
black racer slash the black flash
because they're basically the same thing
how those characters relate to like
death of the endless versus necron and
different things like that
because any guy anybody who's been
reading dc comics for quite some time
knows that there's all these different
versions of death right necrons like
death for the green lanterns and
like the black racer slash the black
flash is death for the new gods and the
flashes and so on and so forth so here's
the important thing to understand here
in dc comics you only really have one
absolute
representation of death and that's death
of the endless that's really all it is
everybody else is really more akin to
like charon right the fairy man from
greek mythology who would take people
across the river styx
that's really all they are in in some
form or fashion right necron is almost
kind of like this being that sort of
stands in this kind of purgatory-like
place um and
those individuals who basically die kind
of pass through his realm which sits as
what most people refer to as a temporary
way station
until they actually go to the realm of
death of the endless where they
live their eternal life and whatever
afterlife awaits them
uh the black racer the black flash
functions more or less the exact same
way
the black racer aspect is what takes the
new gods from their existence to the
realm of death and
the black flash does the exact same
thing but for speedsters the difference
is that when speedsters die they join
the speed force right that's kind of
their afterlife
um now a lot of this really came by way
of action comics number 894
which was the aftermath to blackest
night and there's a point where lex
luthor actually encounters death of the
endless and asked the question about
blackest night right
like was that you were you the reason
why people were coming back from the
dead and the answer that death gives is
not necessarily a direct one like no i
didn't do that
here's how it happened that's not really
the answer that we get instead it's just
kind of like yeah i saw all that go on
and it seemed like everybody was having
a lot of fun
people do escape the realm of death i am
pretty busy and so what that really
pointed to is the idea that necron is
not a representation of
death of the endless as far as as it
pertains to the green lanterns necron
is a wholly different entity of his own
court and that he was basically able to
bring people from the realm of the dead
into the realm of the living hence the
blackest night event so it's not as
though all these different avatars
are just aspects of death they're just
beings that are out there and this is
really shown by the level of power they
have
necron can be defeated the black racer
the black flash they can be defeated
death of the endless
cannot be defeated if death of the
endless were to show up and face off
against the justice league they would
all die like
she represents a concept and ideology
and so the only way the death of the
endless could truly perish
is if all things simply just cease to
exist so having said that this basically
picks up with barry allen once he's
bonded to the black racer and the
revelation
that he had basically killed darkseid
while he was imbued to the black racer
using the anti-life equation as it was
controlled by mobius and one of the
things this kind of hit on here is sort
of a repeat of what we had previously
seen
in the sense that he doesn't really want
to be separated from the black racer or
the black flash that he wants to control
it but this is kind of like an internal
struggle because it's not as though
barry's operating of his own accord and
in fact he manages to seize control if
only for a moment and then
breaks away from the black racer right
literally manages to separate himself
and then he just runs as fast as he
possibly can
ah that that he can basically outrun
death now this is the second time we've
seen this
the first time we saw it we didn't
necessarily see it happen
it wasn't really until you got to like
flash rebirth and the aftermath of final
crisis
that we actually found out what was
going on right in the original crisis
undefined nurse event barry allen was
believed to have been dead which paved
the way for wally west to become the new
flash
over the course of the entirety of the
90s and the
mid to late 2000s but when barry allen
came back in 2009 with final crisis
and then that was followed up with flash
rebirth by jeff johns it basically gave
us this this depiction or kind of
established to us
that following the events of crisis on
infinite earth that barry allen had just
been outrunning death all this time and
that during the events of final crisis
he was able to literally
escape the the speed force and basically
get away from death
and so because of that very outrunning
death this is not a new concept but it's
also a little bit different here because
of the fact that there's al there's
almost kind of understanding between the
two of them in the sense that it's one
of these things where death sort of
plays these games and says like or at
least uh the black racer plays these
games and says
if if darkseid himself could not conquer
me what chance do you think you have
and even kind of makes these things of
like death is precious to you death
created you right death created you when
it took her right when it took your mom
nora allen now of course we know that
eobard thon killed nora allen but
death was kind of like the follow-up
right like she died and then she was
whisked away by death but it's one of
these things where notice
that uh the black racer doesn't really
say me he doesn't say like you know when
i took her right i am precious to you i
created you that's not really what
what's being said here it's
death did this right so whisking barry
allen off to the realm of death is more
or less what this whole thing is but in
that moment he has this kind of of
he kind of gets this back and forth and
he actually ends up not really coming to
terms with the black racer but kind of
having this bit of a conversation with
the black racer and this is a really
cool moment here
right because what ends up happening is
the black racer basically says like this
is central city right when they kind of
stop for a minute he says like this is
central city right this is the home of
the flash that which the flash fought
and protected
for eons right 2.5 million people live
here now one of the things that the
black racer says is like i am what you
need to learn if
life is to continue now look at the
streets that you would protect this is
an important thing here
because barry allen has largely just ran
away from death that's the story of
barry allen there is
truth to the statement that death
created barry there is an absolute truth
there that in the aftermath of barry
allen's mom dying that that her death
and the concept of death had basically
dominated his life
right the entire flashpoint event was
based on him trying to go back in time
and save his mom's life and keep her
from dying which he succeeded in doing
and then turn the whole world upside
down in an alternate timeline
but like crisis on infinite earth
outrunning death for 20 years until he
managed to come back
constantly trying to get away from death
just refusing to die
and it's one of these things where it's
like this has to happen right like death
has to exist and
death has to have a host and black racer
kind of races off you know just kind of
takes off and it's like i'm going to
kill everybody and it's like you know
can barry allen possibly stop this from
happening and as barry does this and is
very chases down this black racer
and bears witness to all these various
people who were dying
barry comes to the realization that this
has to happen that if death does not
have a host that death would just
run rampant there'd be nobody to curtail
death there'd be nobody to reel it in
nobody to keep it kind of chained and
occur you know
and operating the way it's supposed to
now there's precedence for this we saw
that with hal jordan when he was bonded
to the spectre right in the aftermath of
like emerald twilight and all that kind
of stuff that hal jordan became the new
host for the spectre and then eventually
they were separated and the specter had
no hosts and so the spectre went on a
war path right the representation of
god's vengeance just went on this
absolute war path and so the idea is
that if black racer functions
more or less the same way even if it's
only a concept or something akin
to the idea of death if there's no one
there to chain it it would just run
rampant because all it does
is kill people and so there'd be no
discerning factor there there'd be no
instance of like you know this guy's 26
years old in the prime of his life
there's nothing wrong with him he didn't
walk in front of a vehicle or anything
like that it's not his time and death
would just
snatch him up because death just kills
right and it would kill indiscriminately
and so because of that it's one of these
things where barry basically realizes
that the only way
for this to work right the only way for
him to successfully bond
to to the black racer is for him to take
a life to kind of
cement the relationship between the two
that with barry allen
taking a life using the scythe of the
black racer that in turn it would make
him
into the new black racer right he would
basically become the new living
embodiment for
the black flash black racer what have
you and so he actually ends up going
directly to iris west
now it's not really done with the
intention of killing iris west that's
not his goal here
the reason why he ran to iris west and
is something that she begins to pick up
on
when he basically brands the scythe and
transforms into the black flash if she
realizes you came here because you know
i'm the only one that can stop you
right i'm the only one that can keep you
from doing this i'm the only one that
can pull you back from the brink
if this was anybody else if it was
anybody else out there
in the world you would have struck them
down with a scythe and it would have
been the end of them they would have
died and you would officially become the
black racer but even if only on a
subconscious level
you knew that i could pull you back you
couldn't bring yourself to kill me and
so
in that moment the idea of barry being
taken over by the black
black racer is temporarily halted and
the black racer even in an effort to
kind of tempt barry allen
jumps like kind of manifests in
different forms then like in turn what
would happen you know maybe i should
just
see what would happen if gorilla grodd
had my power what kind of pandemonium
and chaos that he could bring to this
place
and so barry kind of says okay fine so
just one life all i have to do is take
one life
and then it'll cement us and and the
black racer is like yes and he's like
okay you got it i'm going to kill you
and immediately chases after the black
racer right now when this happens a
black racer is like what
that's not how this is supposed to be
right that's not how this is supposed to
work and
like immediately just goes fleeing right
so like the shoe is totally on the other
foot and it's like begging barry allen
to stop now ultimately barry allen
drawing the scythe back
does manage to kill the black racer but
he kills the black flash the problem
with this
is that as soon as that happens he's
almost kind of greeted with like this
sort of depiction of his mom with this
kind of you know
afterlife s concept but when he kills
the black racer like the black racer as
an ideology right the the kind of
representation of death
is just totally unhinged right it's
completely and totally released
death is 100 free for the first time now
remember this is kind of uh this is kind
of dc playing it fast and loose right dc
saying
the black razer kind of is or maybe it's
not a version of death yeah
so you can just kind of take it for what
it's worth but what it basically means
is it's almost a repeat of what we saw
with like the spectre and hal jordan
that because there's nobody anchoring it
there barry allen realizes
death has to have a host death has to be
has to be bonded to someone that if it's
not bonded to anybody because darkseid's
no longer alive to control death death
would just
run unfettered across all of existence
and just kill every single person that
it can possibly come across
and so barry ultimately makes the
sacrifice right he says fine
then i will do what i have to do right
in this instance i will rebond myself to
the black racer and i will officially
become the new harbinger of death
and that's what he does right he
combines his power with the black racer
and goes forward
accordingly so with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you